hey I'm here at Google i/o and I'm
sitting in a brand new Chevy and this is
Android auto so Android auto is
basically your Android smartphone but
bigger and built right into your car so
you can see here in the entertainment
console you've got google maps there's a
music feature here where you can pull up
you know your various apps like pandora
spotify and usually it's stored on your
phone and then there's this home screen
that you can see has your notifications
it pulls from google now from your
calendar alerts so it's pretty cool and
it uses google's voice technology which
i think works really well what's the
weather tomorrow tomorrow's forecast for
san francisco is 68 degrees with fog
pretty typical but it's also got
Google's contextual features so since I
just asked about the weather I can now
ask what about friday in New York
Friday's forecast for New York is 79
degrees and sunny pretty cool it's nice
to see the technologies in our cars
finally catch up with the technology in
our pocket
you